que le premier ministre Legault
a nommé responsable du dossier,
il est avec nous en direct.
Gilles Bélanger, député
d'Orford, adjoint parlementaire,
donc, du premier ministre,
sur le volet Inter
Bonsoir, Monsieur Bélanger.
- Bonsoir, Monsieur Roy.
- J'ai un tableau que je vais
vous montrer. Vous allez
me confirmer si c'est vraiment
les vrais chiffres ou si c'est
des voeux. Bon, on revient à
janvier 2021. Il y avait 250 000
foyers qui restaient à brancher
haute vitesse. Il en resterait
aujourd'hui 70 000. Est-ce que
c'est une vision optimiste, les
70 000, ou c'est vraiment ça?- s
le fond, il y en avait en 2018
au-dessus de 300 000.Près de 38,
250 000. Et aujourd'hui,
je vous dirais à peu près 70 000
qu'il reste à brai
le 30 septembre.
- Bon. Et d'ici le 30 septembre,
e qu'il va arriver?
Combien vous allez en brancher
avec la méthode traditionnelle
de la fibre?
- Moi, j'hésite à dire
"la méthode traditionnelle",
parce que dans le fond, on a
une boîte à outils. On peut pas
"fibrer" tout le monde. La fibre
optique, ça coûte 20 000 à
30 000 dollars le kilomètre.
Donc, il y a des milliers de
foyers qui vont être branchés
par le sans fil, et la meilleure
solution que nous avons trouvée,
c'est SpaceX Starlink, qui offre
des vitesses, des débits
vraiment intéressants. Donc,
tout le Québec, je vous dirais
qu'on a déjà une couverture à
100 % en date aujourd'hui.
Mais maintenant, il y a
des contrats qui orats qui orats
pour la fibre optique. Et si
ces contrats-là ont un retard
de livraison, le sans fil
va être fourni, que ce soit
en attendant ou de façon
permanente, pour s'assurer que
vraiment, notre promesse
d'offrir 100 % Internet à tout
le Québec, elle est réalisée
au plus tard le 30 septembre.
- OK, mais des 70  qui qui qui i
attendent, qui veulent avoir
la haute vitesse, vous dîtes que
tous, d'ici la fin,,,,,,
s'ils n'ont pas vu le camion
de fibre s'activer, vont pouvoir
s'abonner à Starlink d'Elon
Musk, les satellites, les 3000
satellites qui font le tour de
la Terre, et vous allez payer
une partie de l'installation,
pas mal l'installation, et
vous allez payer 40 dollars
par mois. Est-ce que c'est
à peu près ça?
- Tout à fait. Le tarif va être
compétitif, au filaire.
Et puis, ça va se faire avant
le 30 septembre, parce qu'on a
des équipes, sur le terrain, qui
évaluent si les fournisseurs
vont avoir un retard ou pas.
Et déjàculé certaines
régions avec une offre sans fil.
Et lorsque le filaire, parce que
moi, je préconise que la fibre
optique est la meilleure
technologie à long terme,
lorsque le filaire sera
disponible, le citoyen aura
le choix : soit qu'il garde
Starlink SpaceX ou qu'il désire
s'abonner au filaire
fibre optique.
- C'est à peu près 140 par mois,
Starlink, pour avoir accès à
Internet haute vitesse.
Vous allez défrayer combien de
ce 140 dollars pour les gens?
gratuit.
C'est livré à la maison.
On défraie 40 dollars par mois.
Si, après six semaines, le
client, sa fibre eble,
il va pouvoir cesser le service.
Le citoyen n'est pas commis à
du long terme. Mais je peux vous
dire, moi, j'ai passé le mois
de juillet à faire le tour du
Québec jusqu'à Blanc-Sablon aux
portes du Labrador, j'ai testé
dans 56 endroits différents, et
au niveau de
la solution Starlink. Ça va être
une des solutions qui va aider,
au niveau de la mobilité,
dans le futur.
- Comment on fait,
très concrètement, là?
Dans les Laurentides, moi,
je connais plein de gens qui
attenden
optique, c'est pas demain matin.
Puis, Bell ou d'autres nous
disent : pas avant six mois,
un an, on sait pas trop.
Comme vot au début,
c'est trop cher les compagnies,
même avec l'argent que vous
leur donnez. Bref, comment
ils font, concrètement, pour
recevoir la coupol
- Eh bien, avant, je dirais
qu'en 2023, il y a une promesse
de brancher toutes les régions.
Nous, ça fait 20 mois et on est
out le monde.
Pour la coupole, il y a une
carte interactive qui existe.
Chaque citoyen a accès à
une carte interactive au Québec.
Ça va lui dire qui va
le brancher et quand.
S'il y a un retard, les dates de
retard ou les dates cibles sont
inscriterte.
Et il y a un scénario, il y a
une option qui leur est offerte
pour s'assurer qu'ils ont
Internet haute vitesse au plus
tard le
- OK, c'est dans un mois, ça.
Donc, on va sur le site...ça s'?
Est-ce qu'on l'a? Oui, on l'a.
Quebec.ca/carte-internet-haute-
vitesse. On regarde s'il y a du
retard ou pas dans la région.
Et sinon, le 30 septembre,
on s'abonne aux satellites.
Qu'on a vus, d'ailleurs. Est-ce
qu'on a la photo? Avant de se
quitter, vendredi, les genspenss
ovnis dans le ciel du Québec.
C'était le lancement
de 30 satellites supplémentaires
d'Elon Musk, qu'on voit sur la
photo. Ça, c'est le reflet du
soleil sur les panneaux solaires
des satellites. C'était très...
très intrigant, vendredi, dans
la nuit. C'était ça, les fameux
satellites.
Monsieur Bélanger, merci.
- Monsieur Roy...
- Oui?- Nous avons monté toute a
carte du début... Il existait
pas de carte au Québec.
C'est le Québec qui l'a monté
de A à Z.
- Très bien! Merci beaucoup,
Monsieur